mr. was taken to UMC where police
continue to rain outside the building
the governor made a visit to the
hospital as well that's where reporter
Kristen Drummond joins us live Kristen
Kirsten the hospital entrance here on
wellness way stays busy various people
continue to come by to show their
concern for officer Nick aloneness the
officer who was shot in the head while
on duty last night various people from
community
state leaders came by to show their
support including governor Steve sisal
AK Steve select said this afternoon he
did not want to make a comment on camera
but I did watch as he addressed officers
to thank them for their work now
throughout the day officers supported
each other with hugs and prayers and
even a few in the community also came to
top of police and drop off a few items I
just want to pay my respects and just
bring down a token of my appreciation
for the police officers and their
families and I just want to bring them
some doughnuts today our cameras
captured Sheriff Joe Lombardo also
speaking with officers hospital staff as
well as the Las Vegas fraternal order of
police offered relief with food and
water now just up ahead there is a group
gathering here this is a group with the
Las Vegas thin blue line they are all
gathering here to show their support for
officer Nick aloneness tonight and that
is happening just across the street from
the hospital you can see the thin blue
line American flag is already Adam we'll
have much more on their efforts and what
they're doing later on tonight but Metro
Metro Police are asking the entire
community to have thoughts and prayers
for officer Michael onus as he is on
life support right now reporting live
outside UMC Kristen Drummond 8 news now